*Moody synth music*
*Tape Player clicks*
*Answering machine beeps*
huh buh, heyah, the driver's not here yet and the hotel's got no cigarettes.
Where's Julie? Julie? Where? Ah, ahhh, hell!
*Answering machine clicks and beeps*
Buuuh, hey, it's uh, it's Nick again, look can uh, look can we send someone out to get me, uh, some brown shoe polish
uh, uh, uh, ham sandwich and uh, and uh, uh, some boxers, alright.
*Answering machine clicks and beeps*
Ah boy. Aaaah! The ice man! the ice man! Bah, hell, god.
Ah hey! Uh, it's Nick, look, uh, don't ask me how but I manage to, uh, to lock myself inside my trailer
So if you could send someone over to get me out I, uh, I'd appreciate that
Otherwise I'm gonna have to crawl out and get me a mundo (gasp?)
*answering machine clicks and beeps*
Look Eddie, uh, can you bring my wallet to set today, I uh, I left it in your bathroom this weekend.
It's, uh, it's snakeskin. Ah, you know I love that thing.
*click*